uh there's no doubt that the doctrines
of warfare were indeed as Dr Peterson
points out formulated several centuries
after Muhammad's death and that uh they
were formulated during an imperial
period there's also no doubt that
they've never been reformed or rejected
and that the apparatus to do so does
exist there are still these schools of
jurist prudence operating and not one of
them has ever said wait a minute we
maybe we shouldn't wait war against
unbelievers in order to establish the
hemony of Islamic law against them they
had a golden opportunity to do this as a
matter of fact after 9/11 when there
were people who were pointing out that
these doctrines existed then was the
time when the New York Times went to
alasar University in Cairo and said it
was a beacon of moderation trying to
teach Muslims that Warfare was not the
way to go and alasar University in Cairo
has given its endorsement to a manual of
Islamic law that says very clearly that
the Muslim Community must wage war
against Jews Christians and zoroastrians
until they either become Muslim or pay
the non-muslim pole tax the gizia that
we both mentioned now they could have
rescinded their endorsement of such
ideas at that time they could have
backed up the New York Times wishful
thinking and shown themselves in some
way to be moderate they did not do so
and there still continues to be no major
Islamic Authority that has done so and
and so what I am doing in my work is not
trying to make the case any better or
worse than it is and I invite any
fair-minded person to look at the books
that I've written I never actually say
contrary to Dr Peterson's claim that the
jihadist version of Islam is the true
Islam there is no Central Authority in
Islam there's no Islamic Pope and there
is no person who can pronounce and say
this is Real Islam and this isn't but
there's no doubt that the jihadists are
using the the claim that they represent
the true Islam and are buttressing that
claim by reference to these traditional
elements of Islam to gain recruits
around the Islamic World until we
recognize that and challenge it rather
than try to wish it away it will
[Applause]
continue do Dr Peterson um you've
mentioned on several occasions that this
may just be a misunderstanding between
the Western World and non-muslims and
Muslims how do you contend that we
should deal with the threat of terrorism
in places not just inside countries like
Iraq and Afghanistan but where it's been
exported abroad we've seen it in England
uh France um of course in the United
States how do you explain the phenomena
of of terrorism how should the United
States or even Western Nations respond
to that threat well I don't see it as a
misunderstanding between Muslims and
non-muslims I I see it as uh you know
there really is and in a sense we are
really not dis agreeing that much except
I do object to the idea that I'm making
up pretty things in the Quran playing
games sing it away I'm not I have a
pretty cold re realistic view of the
Islamic World terrorism Islamic
terrorism really does have roots in in
actual parts of the tradition of Islam
I'm simply arguing there are people out
there no major schools yet and no
authorities there is no Islamic Pope to
uh for example to issue some sort of
encyclical denouncing terrorism nobody
has that kind of authority um but there
are voices out there and some pretty
prom ones who have who have come out
even even some pretty anti-American
shakes in Saudi Arabia were critical of
of of the 911 attacks for example uh not
as critical as I would like them to be
but they were critical of those attacks
because of their because of their
assault
on because of their assault on civilians
and so on and so forth um and they're in
their failure to discriminate between
between military combatants and others
um how would I like to see us respond I
think that there's uh you know I've said
already that I'm a supporter of The
Surge and I'm supporter of the war in
Afghanistan I think a a major military
response is necessary in some areas I
think we ought also to be fighting the
war of ideas in various ways which we're
not doing at one point um I was told
that the US was actually cutting back on
broadcasting of idea programs into the
Middle East and was broadcasting
American popular culture for example and
I'm not making this up Britany Spears um
true now I can't imagine a stupider
policy than that to reinforce all the
the islamist stereotypes about the West
uh that's the kind of thing we've we've
been doing um but uh but there are
elements there are little tiny elements
out there in this very dysfunctional
period of Islamic history little Embers
out there that I like to see us blow
upon if we can to Fan them into life I
don't know how we can do that this is a
very difficult question uh because if
you you know if these people are seen as
somehow CIA supported or something like
that that's the kiss of death to them um
but but we ought to be encouraging
hoping for doing everything we can to to
sort of support the mainstream support
excuse me the moderate reinterpretation
of these elements in Quran or and in
Islamic tradition and to to reinforce uh
those peaceful Elements which I insist
I'm not making up they are there they're
legitimate
interpretations thank you very much um
they're they're legitimate interpret I
know I'm going to lose this debate but
it doesn't matter think think of me as a
martyr um thanks that don't do that hold
on